today's episode is brought to you by
movement movement watches was founded on
the belief that style shouldn't break
the bank
with over 1 million watches sold to
customers in 160 plus countries didn't
even know there were that many countries
around the world movement watches has
solidified itself as the world's fastest
growing watch company
it's got classic design quality
construction and styled minimalism it's
they're very cool I've checked him out
got one get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to M
V M T comm slash Congrats that's M V M t
comm slash congrats this episode is also
brought to you by Square cash everyone
is switching to the cash app alright
because it's the easiest way to pay
people back you don't know if the
with money and it's all dirty
you touch money it's an immediately you
sick oh cool you want touch money and
immediately you can get polio so this
app is the best way to pay people back
everybody's got in most payments
Foursquare cash can be deposited to your
bank in seconds if you use other apps to
pay people you Koda this one's the best
download free square cash app for iOS or
Android now
[Music]
welcome to congratulations to the
podcast from from live to you from Los
Angeles California and when people say
Los Angeles
I wanna pop home so yeah extra extra
read all about it crystal ease back in
LA he was in Montreal or how we like to
call it oh hey what's up babies you know
I got I got I got a lot of Canadian
babies out there man and they're cool
they're very nice and I love them and
dude the shows in mom clay were amazing
man they really were dude everybody
turns out it's French's dude
everyone is so French's they're
it's unbelievable
there's so French that they all have
hairy chests even if the shave them that
poof back there so French Sun believable
I was there for the jfl just for last
festival which is awesome I actually
have been there maybe six or seven times
and this year was by far the most fun
I've ever had
I was with good people good friends nice
food don't really care about it got
Starbucks all I care about
chilled met ours Barker huge in
Australia um nice guy he thought I was
his driver when I was a new face in 2009
in Just for Laughs and he was like hey
uh you take me to the airport and I was
like no I'm a comedian he was like oh
okay and then he came up to me recently
I just feel ass and he was like hey man
I wanted to meet jump credit I'm Marge
and I was like I yeah I got a funny
story I told him about that and he
apologized and I was like dude you don't
have to apologize
so he's super nice and he's we're
gonna kick it him up in when I go to
Australia that's what we said so I went
I saw I was in Montreal and I played
that venue which is one of the best
venues I've ever played it's called the
Olympia but also it's called lil Olympia
which is a the most French thing of all
time dude if you put an L '
in front of it that's so funny
you know like it's so French to be like
we're playing Oh little imp eeeh Hey
limpia
and then you see it on on other
websites and it's like Olympia so it's
like what we doing we doing this French
or not I don't like it it's like
cool some people are French's people
aren't but pick one
it's like 70% French and they'll talk to
your French first they'll be like
Bonjour a balupu but - boo boo and
you're like oh hey yeah no no no that's
not for me and they're like what's up
switch mode engage what's up that little
tap tap a blue blue blue no no engage
English hello hey what's up and a super
French thing to do and I don't know if
it's a french-canadian thing to do but
this is the most I've dialed it down to
the most French thing you can do in in
the world and maybe I would I should say
french-canadian thing you can do in the
world is if you're in a position if
you're talking to somebody who is
serving you or whatever it is like a
bartender or or somebody at Starbucks or
somebody a restaurant a waiter if you
say hey can I get salt or something this
is what they do and this happened to me
multiple times and it happens to me
every year they go like this yeah I just
have to go do this one thing and then
I'll and then I'll grab you the salt why
the do I care what you gotta go
well it's like it's like listen I'm
serving you I want you to know you're
not high on my list that's what they do
and it happens so much dude and it's
very weird it's a very weird thing it's
like I'm a server but just so you know
this is my job I'm still a real person
and I'll you up the ass if you get
some attitude
it's weird dude hey can I get a straw
sure sure I just need to drop this off
and then I'll bring one oh I don't
really oh that's cool what are you doing
after that I don't give a hey dude
did I ask for a straw or did I ask for
your to-do list
hey dude if I asked for you to do list
give him a list but if not just get the
straw that's the most
french-canadian thing to do so
yeah it's also really funny how how like
to guess if somebody's French or not
like to be like I think that guys maybe
just Canadian and then he walks up and
he's like just look - look look look
look - closer look and you're like okay
it's French should have seen it with the
chest hair peeking out of his from
boatneck and high socks and high shorts
so the venue was awesome at the Olympia
Olympia how do you want to call it
I had Theo von - a guest set who killed
and then my buddy Michael anoche opened
for me who killed he was a new face one
of the new faces there at the at the at
the just for last festival which was
great he was really really excited about
that and a lot of the new faces he opens
for me and I was really proud of him to
get that but there's a lot of uh there's
a lot of new faces that were really good
man I caught some of them and it was
cool to see that it brought me back to
when I was a new face in 2009 and now
I'm an old face they should have old
faces in Montreal but yeah they're very
cool and there's so many shows they're
going on and I did a TV taping for
Canada which nobody will see because
it's on TV in Canada I swear to God I do
these Canadian TVs are Canadian TV shows
I probably done them about four times
literally never got one tweet don't know
when it airs don't know when it comes
out don't know what network it's on
literally zero tweets in the world to me
it's the weirdest thing who was watching
Canadian TV not Canadians because don't
get tweets so I did that I did some new
material on that and I met a lot of
South African comics which was really
cool I got to meet some of those guys
and they were in that's the cool thing
about just for laughs is that all
the comedians from all across the world
come and there were some Australian guys
there were some said he said
African guys and I don't know it was
just it was cool
I don't know how people drink
people we were at the bar at the Hyatt
every night and everybody was so drunk
and I don't drink you know and I would
wake up feeling like piss how do you
drink and then wake up at like my
manager dude first of all he
sounds like this alright it's like the
most manager voice of all times like
long walk and every time I try to pitch
him a show that I want to sell to a
network he says I walk yeah there's a
there's a show in there okay and it's
never good enough I can be like yeah
it's about I could literally pitch him
the show of Game of Thrones and I could
have all of the episode arcs and all
throughout all seven seasons and at the
end he'll be like alright there's a show
in there alright maybe get the Dragons
earlier you know there's a show in there
and so now me and my other agent we
make fun of them all the time and
we'll be like will be like any time
we're like any time anything we'll be
like eating a sandwich I'll be like
how's the sandwich I don't lock there's
tuna in there like there's tuna in there
you know yeah it's gonna be good
everything's gonna be fine
oh man it's so funny
God so yeah so shout-out to a manager in
my agent make like life better for me on
the road and so what was I talking about
though him talking about why did I bring
him up oh yeah he'll drink he's
by no means does he drink all the time
at all but like when he does he does it
like a social person and then afterwards
he'll be he'll like email me at like
7:00 in the morning and I'll be like no
it's not in the morning you know yeah
wake up yeah I'm like are you hungover
he's like
look I'm yeah all right I drank but you
know the alcohols in there are but like
you know now this I drank coffee was
coming in there you know it's coming
fine you know okay
everything'll be fine I mean did it's so
funny man
he has no shows for media presence - the
guy's killer so yeah so I don't know how
they do this my managers my
friends my opener they all drink and
then they wake up and they wake up way
early er than me and I my buddy
dude a few episodes ago I talked about
my buddy who his name is Zack and and he
was a and I told you I had some people
over and he was the guy talking about
the music that like no matter what music
I played all come on go play better
music
remember that guy if you're an avid
listener to congratulations you know who
I'm talking about
so hey oh by the way my manager sent off
a me an email and it sound like a 747
took off because he's got it a
mail app one firearm it would one fire
but um so my producer Tom imagine with
using my manager but anyways right next
to me sent over 40 cents look at Lala
there you know in there okay there's a
747 jet engine in there okay so anyways
Zack danke vo which is a satalia
his name is Zack danke vo it Italian
okay here's the deal man last time I
brought him up he came to Montreal with
us okay I brought him up last time but I
didn't say his name didn't want people
to you know I don't like to say
people's names if I'm gonna you know
obviously he's one of my best friends
but I'm still lightly making fun
of him I'm Jocelyn up his ego a little
bit maybe I don't want to I don't
want to up you know anybody's day
so he's like thanks for mentioning me in
the podcast didn't mention my name I was
like well I did that because I don't
wanna he's like you can't give me credit
bro
so and he's always laughing always
laughing I'll be like what he eaten to
be like again Hannah - hey
it's very weird so there's banana in
there I mean right in there right but so
so he is like so we came to Montreal
with us and the dude is so weird
look he's one of my best friends all my
friends are weird and I'm weird
I'm not saying I'm not weird but this
guy first of all he's a white guy I
guess I think maybe he's Puerto Rican -
he always like his like him a little bit
Puerto Rican though he's he's the kind
of guy who's okay here's what he is all
right first of all the guy drinks a
gallon of iced tea a day
he's always got like and he walks like
Oh J like he's been playing
football for four seventy years doesn't
okay yep and doesn't play football but
he walks he's got a really high ass like
it's on his shoulders like if he has to
take a dump he has to have his
knees so far forward and he and he's and
his shoulders are on the on the
his neck it hurts his neck when he takes
his because it's up against
the back you know what I mean drinking
iced tea while he's doing it and you
know he's got a medium-sized penis
that's the thing like you know he's got
the most medium-sized penis if aliens
came down I've never seen his dick but
if aliens came down he just screams
medium sized penis like if aliens came
down and they were like we need to see
the regular penis so when we become
human we need to know what the medium is
and you get him and he'd be standing
there and he'd be like and they'd be
like okay that is the most medium-sized
penis and then he'd be like so
I'm Puerto Rican little bit we didn't
ask Zak right so then he's but he's also
this is why I can't trust the
his lips are the same color
as his skin like God didn't finish yeah
oh dude you lip you know people like
that their lips are the same color as
their skin God
didn't finish yeah hey what happened
God ran a pink dude what happened when
God was making you oh we ran out of pink
Jesus Christ was like there's no more
pink we need to go to Costco and get
more pink but right now zach done co vo
needs to come out and then he pushed him
out of his mom's and the doc
was like it's a boy and smacked
him anyway and then Jesus was like
whoops his ass holes too high
oh well that's Zach danke vo and
he drinks a gallon of iced tea
every day no doubt by 40 he's
gonna have zero feet because they're
gonna have to get lopped off cuz drinks
too much sugar and smokes dude in the
guy smokes and the guy gets a
every I swear to God every you got
crocodile crocodile arms every time we
go every time we're at dinner
and the bills just about to come he's
gonna go outside for a cigarette and
then he goes and then the VIP bill comes
and I split bills pay for the bill I'm
like all right let's see if he's just a
dog where's the bill I said you were
smoke and we paid for it
oh sorry man I mean so there you go
there you have it Zach danke vo there
you go Bob said your name love the guy
love him love travelling with him nicest
guy really fun really good guy never
doesn't wear a baseball hat never saw
the top of his head him and Garth Brooks
swear to God never seen the top of
either of their heads always wearing a
cowboy hat always wearing a baseball hat
dude Zach packs first of all we went to
Montreal for three days three that's
three days I brought a backpack this guy
brought for real okay first of all he
brought the medium-sized bag to match
medium-sized penis you know the
medium-sized bag that everybody has that
you can carry on and then he brought the
big bag that one that
girls bring when they go somewhere for
six days okay so he's got the
medium-sized bag and the big bag now
he's in Montreal for three days now I
know he's I know the big bags full of
iced tea obviously so in the medium bag
dude the guy I say well okay so he's got
the meters bag and the big bag and then
he's also got dude he doesn't have a
backpack he brings a messenger
bag hey dude
you delivering letters dude if you have
a messenger bag let me tell you
something if you have a messenger bag
you're a piece of okay you'd put a
you a div a messenger bag put
another strap on it and put it around
your back you know why you don't work
for FedEx okay you're just some guy at
the airport you don't wanna work for
FedEx if you have a messenger back and
you're you know why messenger
bags suck you put it over your
shoulder and you're walking and it's
bang it against your every step you
take because it's it's like bang it
against your every step you take
and this guy's pushing a medium-sized
bag and a big sized bag and his
shoulders are lopsided and the bags
smacking his medium-sized
every every step this guy takes and I
say you got too many bags and he says
dude he opens the big bag I you not
he's got seven hats seven
baseball hats for three days and four
pair shoes I brought one pair of shoes
zero hats and I'm performing literally
thousands of people have to see me
this guy's wearing oakley's it's
guys in disguise nobody even sees him
even when he's out because he's wearing
so many things he don't need all that
yet burn your satchel put a strap on it
put an extra strap on it put an extra
strap on it dude the guy's unreal and
his lips are the same color as his skin
cuz God ran out of pink
it's unbelievable dude hahaha man me and
my opener we make fun of him so hard and
I make fun of my opener so hard so it's
like ten fold on this guy and he
eats muffins and meat and never
like imagine this guy eating a salad and
they're no imagine this guy eating a
salad oh my god oh it's so funny
we laugh we cry dude what is it about
making fun of your friends that's so
funny
I do like it's so funny and this is why
I'm so this is why I want to be it this
is why I want to be a guy because all we
do is make fun of each other and it's so
funny that's why I'm happier I'm a guy
women don't really do that if you were a
girl you can't do that cuz all the
other girls get their feelings hurt and
that's fine that's what makes women
wonderful so don't come at me but also I
want to look at my friends face my guy
friend and call him a
made ass boy okay and then
laugh and both of us laugh you
Hey you brought a satchel you
if I can't look at my
friend and say that and then have him
laugh and then me laugh and then him
make fun of me for my shorts or whatever
the or how I'm lanky I'd look like
a bird or whatever the and I laugh
we're crying by the end of the
conversation laughing so hard
laugh and charred okay we're laughing
chard and dude
girls don't do that come on girls
do it do it make fun of each other
talk to each other and be like
check out little tits over here
it's a sexist but not really look at you
look at you stupid skirt or some
I don't know what the
but like dude this is why I I
swear this is why none of my
relationships work out sometimes my ex
my exes we'll just they'll be like you
talk harsh and I'm like yo I
love you you know I don't know I do Thai
you know that's how my whole family grew
up though man
I mean my mom would zing my dad hard my
dad would be like I got 50 years
behind me and my mom would like Pat his
belly and be like yeah and 20 pounds in
front of you I mean murder slit
just slammed him dude hey dude where's
the door gunk slammed him he's like the
see an Ace Ventura when Ace Ventura
throws the door in front of the
guy's face and it almost hits
his nose now obviously I'm the only one
that remembers that but still sir
efference my mom slam the
out of my dad every day we laughed my
dad got sense heat but whatever my mom
always got sensi my mom was a can't is
the king that was I'm talking like she
passed away she's the
queen of slamming dude my mom is
the queen of slamming dude that's why I
love slamming you know the man
my mom's queen slam queen
this queen of the slammd there's not a
movie Queen of the Damned or what the
is that
did I make it up what is that something
was the Damned isn't that it wasn't that
that a alia movie I don't know
but whatever well it is Queen of the
Damned with with alia with Stuart
Townsend what happened to that guy dude
hey Stuart Townsend people would tell me
I look like that guy all the time
Stuart Townsend hey man you're you're
from a small village in Great Britain
right you know why because your name is
Stuart Townsend all right Oh Queen of
the Damned tagline all she wants is hell
on earth
I mean they would never make that movie
now first of all because wouldn't put
the Damned and a title Queen of
the Damned all she wants is hell on
earth oh she wants this hell on earth
they make the Huey Lewis song a
remix in all she wants to do is dance
would ruin the movie also would make it
better dude Stuart Townsend is a good
actor and British the most British name
of all time all right
no I'm Stephen Townsend from a small
village in small village and well I
am sort of wampum um he was also in some
movie with yeah gars whatever I
don't know but uh yeah my mom's queen of
the slammd dude so so yeah so I slam so
my buddy slam I love getting slammed
and a chicks don't slam they don't
really slam I mean some chicks slam
comedian chick slam but some chicks
don't slam anyway
slam is good for you though man because
like it makes you know you live from my
family it's how we loved each other it's
how we showed we loved each other
true Slams because you're not
gonna slam somebody you don't
care about because then you don't
because you then it's like a real thing
and you're not that mean you got a
show love by slamming love by
slamming slamming also means but
that's not what we're talking about here
dude and if you think I am go to lunch
Hilux you guys heard about this look
you're unique yaar you're unique okay if
you weren't unique you wouldn't be you
you're snowflake you don't want to you
know you don't walk like everyone else
you don't talk like everyone else
you don't sleep like everyone else so
why is your mattress one size fits all
huh what are you in jail nah the truly
customized mattress will cost you five
to ten thousand bucks now we both know
it's too much but it doesn't cost that
much anymore go to helix sleep calm
answer a few simple questions and
they'll run a 3d biomechanical model of
your body through the proprietary
algorithms they developed with the help
of the world's leading economic and
biomechanics experts the result the most
comfortable mattress you've ever slept
in you lay on it you go like this how
are you guys well I'm just gonna let
that's what happens all right guys look
I'm just gonna take a little your out
before you even hit the matrix helix
customers report a 30% improvement in
overall sleep quality that's what I'm
telling you guys and for couples they
customized each side of the mattress so
I mean you can't you can't lose your
mattress arrives at your door in about a
week okay so that's one week and then
and shipping is completely free that's
why everyone from GQ magazine to four
are talking about helix sleep you have a
hundred nights to try it out that's a
hundred if you don't love it then
they'll pick it up for free and give you
full refund no questions asked what do
you have to lose go to helix sleep calm
/ congrats and get $50 off your order
right now that's helix sleep calm /
congrats for $50 off
Killick sleep calm / Congrats go
hi guys I'm wearing the most comfortable
underwear of all time they're called me
undies the undies are amazing I'm
wearing them right now
Sallah where I'm part of the me on Dee's
family you can be to every pair of me
undies is sustainably sourced and made
from micro modal a fabric that's 3 times
softer than cotton if you haven't tried
it yet you sleep it all right because
it's true they're the most comfortable
you used to buying boring underwear
me undies will change everything they're
cool they got cool patterns cool colors
and they release new limited-edition
patterns each month that will always
sell out this month's pattern patterns
were designed by the legendary 80's
clothing brand cross colors remember
those guys with the names that live up
to their bold design and bright colors
they got like you dig and the og I got
him
I wear them they're very colorful
they're very cool they're very
expressive not boring I got them cuz not
boring and I like to be comfortable
alright so you got to get these neon DS
you've got to see you got to see him for
yourself and right now you'll save 20%
off your first pair and receive free
shipping only at me undies dot-com /
congrats there's a reason me undies has
sold over 5 million pairs to date you'll
feel it when you put them on trust me
and if you don't love your first pair of
me undies they're free get 20% off your
first pair plus free shipping at me on
these calm / congrats that's me undies
dot-com / congrats me on DS dot-com /
Congrats
I'm just trying to help you babies we're
trying to live to the full potential of
babies and some of you guys will become
elders sick cult right we think I'm
starting this to just talk make a little
bit of money now trying to get a cabin
in the woods I keep telling you guys
that
some cult leader you babies um yeah but
I'm gonna start giving out you know for
the people that are the true fans and
really reppin the the podcast you guys
become elders I haven't given out elder
status yet but I will
and that's the true congratulations man
that's why we call this ship
congratulations all comes full circle
dude it's the circle you see that movie
with Tom Hanks and that another
girl that looks you know a little bit
androgynous I don't remember but that
movie the circle robbed him a
title because that's about this dude did
you watch that movie that had no
antagonist at all and was born his
did you watch it was it called the
circle because I should have locked in
the movie theater and then circled right
back out right as a result from the
credits started dunno but it should have
been
what's the tagline let's see the tagline
knowing is good knowing everything is
better
ah slay Z tagline this is the same this
is what the tagline should have been ah
doot da hey cars that's it that's all it
should have been would have meant the
same thing knowing is good knowing
everything is better no and I
mean that movie had no bad guys stuff
just happened and then they were like
it's over um yeah yeah dude
yeah if movies are oh I watched
I put on I was on the plane too on the
way to Montreal and I put on whatever
the the new Furious movie is fad
fate of the furious high by just you
know what call it Fast and
Furious 8 or whatever the it is
fate of the Furious oh really no I was
not the fate you know why because
there's another one after it
there's two more here's the deal alright
these are the people in the movie go to
the look look up the people in the movie
first of all
fate of the furious these are the MU
people in the movie this is the cast of
the movie all right oh you should have
put the thing on this
guy it's not that slow we got the TV all
plugged in he's not using the Apple TV
okay so I slay he slammed me so
hard he just said well we need to fix
the Wi-Fi and that's the bigger the
hardest lamb I've gotten literally all
week well we need to fix our felt hot in
his heart when he said well we
need to fix the Wi-Fi cuz he told me
that I thought last week and I didn't
even do about it so all
right hard to sum of all time but anyway
oh great
just so annoying lost my place
here so these are the people in the
movie
okay these are the people in the inn in
one movie now Vin Diesel
it's a badass Jason Statham it's a
badass Dwayne the rock Johnson so badass
Michelle Rodriguez arguably more about
us Tyrese Gibson no sometimes he's not
but in this movie Savannah's Ludacris
now even though every movie that
Ludacris is in is a comedy no matter
what a badass Charlize Theron fantastic
actress in this movie so badass Kurt
Russell's in it guess what in this movie
Kurt Russell spat ass
Natalie Emmanuel who was like the new
pretty chick that they got to use right
no guess what in this movie it's badass
Luke Evans don't know who that is let me
look up this guy Oh Luke Evans isn't it
Luke Evans is always a Sabattus okay no
I'm going down this list Scott Eastwood
obviously Sabattus Christopher lived you
change it so badass okay now all these
guys are in this movie okay all these
guys all these guys happens in this
movie as you can imagine they gotta up
the state stakes forever
very fast and furious movies so this is
number eight so now you literally have
cars I mean I don't even know what I
want to say you literally have cars
driving out of buildings in going into
other buildings but that happened in
like the fourth one so in this one it's
just like literally cars running over
pandas in outer space I don't know what
the it is but it's just so insane
the most crazy is happening
it's like the whole world's gonna end
now all those bad asses every they have
too many bad asses in that one movie
that those people should be in seven
movies ok but it's one movie all the
shit's going on in this movie and none
of them act like they give a now
that's the movie that they're making of
course but 0 of them give a flying
because they're too badass like Ludacris
will be like ha ha after someone gets
after like someone gets up the
ass well we'll see how it goes the next
time and Tyrese is like well I'm not
gonna let that happen while he's getting
shot in the head and I mean like what's
his name
the rock and Jason Statham who
by the way they're great together and
this is no-knock I like all these actors
they're all better than me but they're
brooding and CID not giving a
about everything that's happened I
mean there's one scene where these
drivers are driving through I don't even
know where they are dude but they're
driving through this crazy like
plant like I don't I don't know what the
it is but like there's these
boulders that are like coming down and
like swinging and crashing into them and
and like every time that comes
close like one of them one of these
big-ass boulders knocks over Teresa's
side mirror and he like waukee's over -
ludicrous and he's like imma get
you for that one man and ludicrous as
they had hey man he almost died you
known him since the first fast and
furious and before that too because in
the first one you guys had back story
you're not sad dude if I'm driving next
to my friend that I've known for yeah
twelve years or seventeen years however
long the franchise has lasted
and he almost got clipped by a
swinging Boulder in his
souped-up Honda I'd pull over Ludacris
is just like haha you got to be more
careful Tyrese hey care hey care more
yeah I know the movie doesn't make sense
and it's fantastic and that's the point
but still human care Marv I mean dude
imagine me in that movie this is
me in that movie the character I play
holy you guys really get the
out of here and then is your clothes
cause of my pissing in my pants and
then I shake my leg and a little turd
comes out no not gross real my
producer goes gross not not gross real I
go like this freeze and the guy goes no
and I go home I god and I drop the gun
run away hey sorry alive and then as I
run away turds come out of my
pants and these shoots after me and hits
me and then I die and I go like
this
oh my god mom a yellow mom cuz for life
everybody can't be a badass in a
movie if everybody doesn't give a
why the do I give a
none of these care that
everybody is almost dying and some
people are dying they don't give a
why the do I have to give a
what are the stakes
nobody would ever cry in a fast and
furious movie Vin Diesel's sister could
die and he'd be like well I guess it's
time to have another sister
those movies make good Jillian's of
dollars that's probably the move
I have to that's what I had to
do if that's what undateable got
cancelled my show
it wouldn't got show if I should have
told the producers hey do it sorry
rewrite it gotta be not given a
more gotta be way cooler chick broke up
with me I gotta go like this guess I
gotta get another Dame Brown and then
the scene at the bar hey guys what's up
you guys hanging out undateable movement
these watches are awesome dude I got one
it's goldish can I swear no it's gold
and it's awesome they're founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank
the watchmakers goal is to change the
wake us consumers think about fashion by
offering high-quality minimalist
products a true revolutionary prices
revolutionary prices with over 1 million
watches sold to customers in in 160 plus
countries around the world movement
watches has solidified itself as the
world's fastest growing watch company
it's cool man
because this minimalist style they have
is very sleek and it's cool you know you
get away with being cool without looking
like an idiot and a jerk by trying to
show off it's really awesome
I got this gold one I really like the
design reminds me of a jet makes me feel
like I could fly people are like oh
that's a cool watch they say what is it
I say
movement it's very cool they start at
just $95 at a department store you're
looking at 400 to 500 bucks dude get out
of here stay home ordered online
movement figured out that by selling
online they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup providing
the best possible possible price classic
design quality construction and styled
minimalism over 1 million watches sold
in over 160 countries get on this get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to M V M t.com
slash Congrats I've been getting common
ever since I put it on dude I'm telling
you from chicks - now is the time to
step up your watch game go to MVM t.com
slash Congrats join the movement square
cash everyone is switching to the cash
app because it's the best way to pay
people back hey dude I got a question do
you like coffin do you like having a
post nasal drip do you like getting
pinkeye no then stop handling money you
goofball get this app dude
friends family coworkers you could pay
lizards back anyone really pay back a
spaceman do it this way sending and
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited
directly in your bank accounts in
seconds that's this fast
that's this fast oh here's how it works
download the square cast app okay well
here's how it works actually okay if
you're a idiot go to the brain
store get a brain and then download the
square cash app link your debit or
credit card select an amount to send and
type in a friend's phone number or email
address to complete a payment then
they'll get a notification that they
just received money that's it there's no
gimmicks Square cash is better than the
other guys this isn't a social network
who wants to have their payments listed
in the feed not me dude you know why I
don't want people knowing when I'm
paying my hookers I'm kidding I've never
done that okay ever actually don't buy
hookers right cuz that's what I'm
basically trying to say anyway back to
square cash so by the way shout-out to
John Murray from the University of
Colorado for being a true baby and
downloading and using the square cash
app get it your kouddous nobody gives a
in the movie fast and furious it's
so ill so ill that's that's the that's
that that's how you got to have a the
franchise there you know I not give it
far anyway maybe that would help all
companies like McDonald's I mean not
that they need help but if they're like
come on down and get a burger and if you
don't like it we don't give up
but a papaya we give you cancer
brenell cuz they do dude it barbers my
mind that people still eat I mean like
my buddy Zach hey Zach you gonna get
cancer
um I don't you know eat that I try and
eat healthy I think about what I eat you
know what I mean I don't always know
what's in my food
but I think about what I eat I think
about trying to go for healthier options
I always try to make the healthier
option and though that's why I've got
six pack kid don't really do a little
bit try it but um so why I got it's why
I'm more cutty than I was
now whenever I said one fire him about
my producer because computer doesn't
work yeah it definitely doesn't work a
computer my internet doesn't work and
it's not working now and it's pissing me
off
because oh that's why actually because
I'm knocked up to the wrong Network so
good because I was gonna take some
questions see who's gonna game the
system with their congratulations pod
style hash tag um but can't get logged
on so it's pretty cool why can't get
logged on I mean really I got it I got
it
I had to log in again to my it's my
house now the text scheme roll keep
rollin through see I thought I was I
thought for a second was a loser okay
but I'm not turns out very cool and I'm
getting a lot of texts and I'm getting a
lot of tweets here you guys can't even
look there are insects in there alright
in there it's gonna be fine okay wait a
minute what the is this did you see
this this has got to be it
this is a joke right that's got to be
Photoshop somebody yeah yeah this guy's
joking
he said he photoshopped a billboard that
said its COO at a time I had like a
baseball field
pretty good Aaron Whalen pretty good
Alan Aaron well and you made it look
like it was true I mean unless they did
and they stole my phrase dude want
royalties so here we go checking
congratulations pod hashtag where's your
farm friend Parker Van Dyke Parker Van
Dyke oh nine I thought I'm assuming he's
talking about Leo I don't know he
actually texted me while I was in
Montreal with a plus three three four
number or whatever s French that's weird
he texted me by he must have known it
must have like felt that I was in
Montreal because I see French but yeah I
haven't talked about him for a little
bit I don't know if he was pretending or
not but he was like he got mad that I
was mentioning him on podcast but I
don't I don't know he's pretending or
not but um anyway he's I don't know I
want to hang out with him or me
that guy's too weird for me to not hang
out with him what do you think about
grown-ass men on scooters Ryan
Hamburglar at Ryan underscore Hamburglar
hey man that's cool
your last name isn't Hamburglar though
so definitely change that I don't know I
mean if that's all you can afford cool
but this is your choice get car
look at them up here oh my god
send me this rare insight for 5-1 at
contrarian and and hey man what the
is wrong with you first of all rare
insight for 51 at contrarian and n and I
have a feeling his name is Ian because
it's contrarian and N it's not cute
change it he's saying lady owns 10
snakes she's too many snakes which is
goddamn right gaming the system
congratulations pawed CBS this morning
woman and he retweeted this woman calls
911 boa constrictor wrapped itself
around her neck and began biting her
face well if you got 10 snakes you're
gonna get bit by one just like my just
like my dad always used to tell me if
you got 10 snakes you're gonna get
choked and bit by one on the face yours
arrived at the home a few minutes later
they had to kill the snake to get it off
the woman she was treated at a hospital
she told the 911 dispatcher she had ten
other snakes hey don't say that after
that oh yo what am i oh dude a snake bit
and choked my face oh yeah yeah oh we
saved you cool I have ten other snakes
then they go like this uh well for
sake and they just like drop the
forceps and we saved this
idiot and she's got ten snakes she
deserves it dude how about this is my
favorite part this is my favorite part
right here come on go back hey go back
that's my favorite part right there I
have a ball constrictor stuck to my face
you have a what boa constrictor stuck to
my face and then the dispatcher
and then the dispatcher says you have a
boa constrictor stuff
I will do you ma'am I mean worst
detective ever Hey hey talk about things
that don't matter more what was she
gonna say 50 how old are you ma'am
50 just hang up the chip I was like okay
well that's so dumb so you got to
be four ma'am how old are you have a
boat constructor stuck to my face
uh how old are you I mean imagine worst
dispatcher first day on the job
dispatcher so Ellen sit down we're gonna
go through calls looks like you have one
right there actually I want you pick it
up hi this is 9-1-1 what's your
emergency high uh my god I have a boa
constrictor stuck to my face oh okay and
how old are you you're fired
okay well I I got fired because I mean
come on dude how old are you you know
how mad I would be if I had a
boa constrictor stuck to my face and I
called 911
and I had to call not like first
of all what is that realization the the
moment where you're like oh I got a call
9-1-1 especially in that moment where
you're like okay this next group choking
me kinda but it should be all good and
then it bites your face it's like oh it
actually hurts
I could probably prom off and you're
like you know what I actually think that
moment we like I think that this is
maybe a job for me calling 911 and
you're like I've lost here I'm this is
it it's a wrap
done the snakes bite in my face and
choking me let me pick up the phone okay
then you go pick up the phone you hit
9-1-1 and you're like they're gonna take
care of this or I'm gonna die so
so you call 911 111 ache wrapped around
your neck and your face is chomped all
right
I mean imagine that take a
second to imagine feeling that you're
driving along right now you're in your
cubicle you listen to congratulations
I'm Chris D'Elia take that out of here
and just imagine a snake oh boa
constrictor wrapped around your neck
squeezing and your face is chomped okay
imagine that imagine how much it hurts
imagine how scared you are imagine how
much you're sweating and also imagine
how much you're pissin and you call
9-1-1 and I were do you think maybe you
might speak you say hey 911 please help
there's a snake around my neck and it's
stuck to my face and then the
9-1-1 operator asks you how old you are
wrapped around my neck and also it's
chomping my face what shoes you're
wearing I I don't see how that I don't
see how that um I have Reeboks on and
through an older version but okay we got
help all the way we need an ambulance
over to some place in Jacksonville
probably we need to send over medics and
we please we need them to send newer
Reeboks there they're gonna have piss
all over those Reeboks I mean what the
also you're never supposed to ask a lady
her age
I mean Wow
thoughts here's a good one
Adam Bogart at Adam Lee five four three
thoughts on these face cutout things
yeah it's good that you know the things
you get at a carnival were you
are it's like a big-ass wooden piece of
and somebody painted somebody's
body on it and you go behind it and you
take a picture hey do it if you do that
that's actually the true definition of a
khuda to finish in the Fukuda for real
who sees a piece of wood with a
hole in it and is like hey let me stick
my face through that I'd rather stick my
dick through that have a glory holes
dude I mean how about glory holes dude
sticking a dick I don't mean like in
porn I mean in real life glory holes
imagine being like well did come in here
to take a but my fits in there
there's probably some sad person on the
other side with a mouth let's see what's
up and then just sticking it in there
and having a guy I mean Jesus I mean
it's insane
that's a very weird thing cool man
loving it I see a lot of people tweeting
the Freak punch freak conch tweets you
can get that merch over at Chris D'Elia
calm rap the podcast you got the
you got ones with the emoji art that we
use for the podcast got the
congratulations artwork you got
congratulations shirts you got also you
got free conch shirts and you also got
we got new ones coming and I'm not gonna
tell you what they say but I think you
might have a feeling what they might say
we're dropping them real soon so anyway
what's up so we do worst Instagram post
of the week oh let me find let me find
the ones I pick I got a little I I
didn't know an Instagram you can art you
can what do you call it save photos and
I got a section in here that's
called uh-oh and I look at the
and I all week I just add two uh-oh oh
here we go I'll just use the last one
here well by the way somebody fell I
don't normally mention the names and
but somebody found one of them last
week was really funny oh wait this guy's
good
oh this guy's good I mean using this one
this guy's on real on real he's got a
lot of followers now the guy is a
handsome dude not gonna lie it's
got a good body he's always in fantastic
places having bond day okay I mean his
biceps or vein he's in front of
like he's takin like 700
pictures in front of fountains like the
guy he sees a fountain and he'll be like
yo yo ass snapped his photo up here's a
picture of him actually wearing a one of
those bandanas over his face
with the skull so it looks like half of
his face is a skull pretty much nothing
I hate more than that cuz you know why
cuz you don't look badass you look like
a guy with a bandana on your face
so this guy is murdering the Instagram
game and here is his caption on one of
his latest things now somebody sent me
this No thank you for it now he writes
well but first of all let me see what
the is he doing ok so this is what
it says okay you got this breathe in
feel that wait a minute I'm sorry I
actually just realized what this said I
forgot no you gotta I gotta do this
again because the next part right after
the feel that is the most unbelievable
thing on social media of all
time okay you so got this I'm sorry it's
not so you got this it's you so got this
which makes it even more oh okay so you
got sorry I it up okay you so got
this breathe in now first of all stop
giving me goddamn instructions and
Instagram I'm just scrolling by look in
a DoubleTap or not you giving me
instructions you piece of uh hey
you my teacher no oh you're just a guy
with a bunch of followers for no reasons
cool a CUDA turn around okay you so got
this breathe in feel that that's my arms
around you not those are my arms around
you which already
those are my arms around you is still
the worst thing on social media but okay
you've so got this breathe in feel that
that's my arms around you
oh no it's not just breathing in and
you're nowhere to be found
you know why because this picture was
tagged in San Fernando Sonora Mexico
okay now does this doesn't surprise me
that your is foreign but you're not near
me your arms that long
no so when I breathe in I do feel it but
what I feel is breath then it says
exhale hear that ah well blood and red
mad cuz this is what this says exhale
hear that
that's the music of both of us laughing
because our faces can't smile big enough
okay man that's horrid hey dude
that's horrid hey man it's not
poetry it's a poetry this guy trying to
imagine this guy
it's a poetry dude okay you still got
this breathe and feel that that's my
arms around you listen ah exhale you
hear that
that's the music of both of us laughing
because our faces can't smile big enough
hey man it's run-on sentence first of
all a poetry that's the music of both of
us laughing hey I can't stand
when someone says something is music
that isn't music okay because you know
what music is music music is music
that's all music is music is not the
sound of people laughing that's laughter
because our faces can't smile big enough
then it says we are happy today today
all things are possible knock them dead
fat flying no today all things are
possible really oh really well you know
it's not possible making a good poem
dude oh you know what else is not
possible me feeling yarns around me cuz
you're in Sonora Mexico and the min-seok
cow I mean dude and it's a picture of
the dude on like a patio
somewhere and he's in all black just
like neo on his day off and ripped jeans
course boots course the pants
are tucked in course blond streaks in
his hair course rings more than Johnny
Depp and a blazer with a
button-down under all black course and
he's you can't see his face it's
like a picture of him dead on
straight on but he's his face is down
and his hairs over his face and he's
doing it looks like he's lighting up a
cigarette but he's not which means he's
just got his hands near his face maybe
he's like he's praying or whatever
whatever dude some of these come some of
these comments under this
picture you motivate me know somebody
writes clean no it's so far on all these
things you so cute I love you so with
Blackhearts this one writes boy your
captions are MF amazing bro you
idiot no they're not no they're not
alright there's got to be the one guy
that is taking the piss come on
let's look at this one oh look at this
idiot who commented on this look
at what this person wrote I show love to
others with small gestures this is a
comment I show love to others with small
gestures that mean a lot if I'm out
shopping with a friend I'll offer to
hold her stuff while she tries on
clothes if I am holding her clothes for
her I'll make sure they're neat so they
don't get wrinkles I have flowers sent
to my friends office just because I know
it'll make her smile I asked my dad for
help with things I don't need help with
just so he knows he's still needed in my
life I listen to my boyfriend's band
even though the style of music isn't my
favorite and I tell my friends to listen
to them to show my guy that I'll do
anything to support something that makes
him happy it's the little things that
count Hey not if they read this you
idiot now your boyfriend knows
that he you don't like his music and
your friend and you're just asking your
dad for help for even though you don't
need it you giving them errands oh you
piece of
hey Dad can you do this for me I need
your help when you don't need their help
and then you're making your old
ass dad go do that he doesn't need
to do just because you want him to feel
needed he doesn't want to feel needed he
wants to feel tired he wants to feel the
chair you making him feel needed
you pace this
dude what the is wrong with this
world man under this comment
somebody's got to be taking the piss out
of this oh man and then you
read the bios of these people and
they're like and it's like look this
this person wrote I do it by having my
actions and words show them that I will
be there for them no questions asked to
any time and then I look at the person's
bio here and gone in a flash
it's contradicting well none of these
people are taking the piss you know what
I'm gonna here comes a comment writen no
there we go wrote no dude you know what
I'm done here man I'm done okay
let's see let me let me around this
out dude support the podcast you want to
be an elder
I haven't labeled an elder you got to
help support bro you got to be
out there repping the podcast hard this
is a war you're either a
baby or a CUDA you CUDA you're posting
long calm captions on Instagram about
how much the world means to you CUDA you
comment taking the piss out of them your
baby that's the kind of support we need
in this cult man help me help
you you can support the podcast anyway
you can't afford it anyway you can go
out there talk about the podcast tell
people their Cudas when they're Kudus
tell people that you look at them
sternly in the face when they're
with you you say turn round I get to
you in the ass for what you did to
me and did too for to society go to
Chris D'Elia calm frickin shirts
support the podcast congratulations
shirts
you got him want to do it subtle with
the artwork with the emoji artwork
you're a baby
view the show go to iTunes and rate and
review the show leave you know five
stars or whatever what the most stars is
tweet me at the hashtag
congratulations pod come to upcoming
shows let me know you're a baby after
the show not during it because if you
call out during the show you khuda it's
simple there's rules you khuda or your
baby upcoming shows we got Nashville
we got Australia I added / I added Perth
I added Brisbane I added Brisbane I
added a Adelaide Narnia I am
going to Salt Lake City Nashville's
almost sold out you guys are the Cudas
and they're coming out man I'm not that
good as you're the babies you're coming
out man pretty soon wife coot is out
there with sign saying no more
new Kris
no more Kris that's what I need you the
most man remember movement watches my
listeners get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t.com / Congrats that's nvm
t-dot-com / Congrats go be sleek and
cool movement watches and square cash
you switched yet from coffin and getting
pink eye to get an app download the free
square cash app for iOS or Android now
merchandise stuff getting restocked this
week we're adding more freaking shirts
and we got a new design that's killer
it's coming up soon you guys gonna flip
dude it's the real baby shirt man it
does not what it says I'm just saying
it's coming up and it's gonna fly so you
guys better be ready you guys better be
checking that website
man on fire go watch it if you haven't
watch it tell your friends hashtag it
man on fire you guys you guys are
awesome man thank you for supporting
this podcast and maybe we want to keep
on trucking do it you made me want to
keep on trucking now
this is progress luck there's a message
in there okay it's gonna be fine